- This is where we will live.
- Only in America.
- Only in America do you add tax
after you see the ticket price.
- Only in America can such a
perfect game exist. Baseball.
- Hamburgers. Cheeseburgers.
Bacon chili cheeseburgers.
Everything on top of everything.
Only in America.
(jazz music plays)
(desk bell rings)
- Welcome to the Economy Value Inn.
How may I help you?
(jazz music plays)
- I am going to America soon.
I'm gonna be a Hollywood star.
- I am looking for instinct.
(grunts)
- Damn.
- (both) We're trying.
(pop music plays)
- This is where we will live.
- You see the rock, right?
- You see a rock.
I see an opportunity.
♪ I slipped on the pebbles
on the way to the gate ♪
- We'll only be gone a short time.
♪ You were up... ♪
- Everyone here is sad.
- That's everywhere, isn't it?
I mean, at least here they give
you all-you-can-eat shrimp.
(pop music plays)
♪ Never live in fear again ♪
- This is life.
We don't always get another shot.
(cheering)
- You always thinking
of going to moon
when we haven't left the ground.
♪ Never live in fear again ♪
♪ No, never again ♪
- You'll see.
I'm going to take you to the moon.
(pop music plays)